this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happening you bad
[__] it's Thursday the 8th of
December I want to welcome the joint
rocket to the podcast listen most
Americans they think they spend around
80 a month on subscriptions when actual
it's closer to 200 you could be wasting
hundreds of dollars each month on
subscription you didn't even know about
that's why I love rocket money formerly
known as true bill the app shows all
your subscriptions in one place and
cancels whatever ones you don't want
rocket money can even find subscriptions
you didn't even know you were paying for
you could even find out that you've been
double charged for a subscription to
cancel subscription just press cancel
and Rocket money takes care of the rest
it's that easy get rid of useless
subscriptions with rocket money now go
to rocketmoney.com Joey again go to
rocketmoney.com
Joey if you if you want to save hundreds
per year that's rocketmoney.com Joey
this thing this app will blow your
[__] mind so cancel your unnecessary
subscriptions right now at
rocketmoney.com Joey remember what Bert
said what Bill Burr said about the bank
taking 28 bucks a month from him and not
even knowing it this is why you take
care of your action with
rocketmoney.com Joey the joint is also
brought to you by liquid IV listen make
sure your hydration stays on top of your
daily list liquid IV is the easy way to
stay hydrated
get five essential vitamins and hydrate
two times faster than with water alone
with one stick of liquid IV look at I
love the concord grape the [__]
strawberry is tremendous cooler weather
makes it easier to miss signs of
dehydration like overheating so it's
even more important to stay hydrated
liquid IV has five essential vitamins B3
B5 B6 B12 and Vitamin C made with
premium ingredients liquid IV is free
from gluten listen five days are coming
kovitz rampant the flu is rampant you
want to stay hydrated do me a favor grab
your liquid IV in bulk nationwide at
Costco or get 20 off when you shop
better hydration at liquid iv.com use
code Joey at checkout again that's 20
off anything with code Joey at liquid
iv.com and this Saturday is UFC 282
we're [__] throwing down Jack at
DraftKings Sportsbook the official
sports betting part of the UFC this
Saturday new customers can get just bet
five dollars pre-fight money line on any
fight of the win and get 150 and free
bets when they do it's that easy I'm
looking at Darren till there's a couple
of Fighters there but I won't know for
sure till the weigh-in right now
everyone can earn up to 50 boost when
you place the same game Paulie on UFC
282 down download the app right now
Sports DraftKings Sportsbook app and
I'll tell you what that little uh
fantasy app ain't bad either you could
download that that app also and remember
that's code Joey this Saturday at
DraftKings Sportsbook minimum age and
eligibility restrictions apply see show
notes for details let's get this party
started it's Thursday morning [__]
smokers
[Music]
welcome to Uncle Joey's Joy
foreign
[Music]
ERS here we are on another Thursday I
think it's the 8th of December I don't
even [__] know anymore does it matter
time just [__] flies no matter what
the [__] you want to do it's been a
great couple days
um
feeling good looking good
the team that 2-0 my wife's [__] uh
basketball team my wife's doing a great
job coaching and [__] uh we went over
there the day for practice what a
[__] nightmare when you try listen
the hardest people to control are seven
[__] young women
it's my wife even told me afterwards she
goes me taking this job and me taking
this [__] coaching job this is rough
on me oh she's going to bed at 10
o'clock 9 30s and [__] so coaching is
not for everybody thank God I'm the
assistant for the assistant for the
assistant to the assistant to the
assistant and I just sit over and yell
rebound defense jump you [__] bite them
you know [__] like that [__] crazy
news yesterday I got uh I talked to
Rogan last night he was telling me about
Caroline's closing and then I went
online I saw it and I'm like what the
[__]
[Music]
you know listen I heard 20 different
stories
I heard that the uh they had to move out
of there the landlord raised the rent
you know what what landlord has them
raised a rent you know what landlord
hasn't done cheesy things during this
[__] uh pandemic you know but
from my perspective I mean as a comedian
how I got into it when I got into it
listen guys when I got into it was
playing the [__] simple
it was 1991 the clubs you wanted to
perform at were Caroline's in New York
City there was just something to that
name
and The Comedy Store in La that that's
all I remember guys I everything else
was background music yeah you wanted to
do a club in Texas and I wanted to play
The Underground but the two main [__]
clubs
where you know
Caroline's on Broadway when I took the
Sony Hall residency I loved it because
of those two words at the end
Sony Hall on Broadway
do you understand the power of those two
[__] words I mean
that's as powerful as can [__] be so
when I was a young comic looking up to
uh you know what comedy clubs I would
write my goals down you know many
[__] times I walked past
uh Caroline's in the summer of [__]
93 when I was delivering sales packages
for phone companies and [__] you haven't
even [__] idea I would walk by
Caroline's every day at the comic strip
and if I got up up that far the 70s to
the 80s I'd stop at uh stand up New York
why I don't know at that time I would
just read their lineups you know like I
would go to Caroline's and see who was
coming and go wow you know this guy's
gonna come here wow this guy's gonna
come that you know so I would go to
Caroline's as a fan like I remember
paying for tickets
to go to Caroline's
forget who the [__] I went to see
who the [__] did I go see I went to see
the chick from Night Court
you know like Marcia and I went to see
somebody else at Caroline's you know I
was already doing comedy
and it was like
I don't I couldn't remember what they
said
I couldn't remember what they said I I
don't remember what they said you know
why
because that was in awe the whole
[__] time
it had to be
yeah like 93 I saw Marsha Warfield and I
saw some other comic too
I forget who maybe Martin Lawrence maybe
I don't know who the [__] it was at
Caroline but they were tremendous and
I'm you know as a [__] comedy fan and
as a future comic I didn't
listen I remember when I heard that
Martin Lawrence made 10 000 an episode
of Def Jam
like I almost have [__] had almost
blew up
hell I'm like 10 000 an episode
I'll never make that [__] money but
I'll be happy with 500 you know what I'm
saying but ten thousand I like I'll
never make like that's the kind of money
when I when I started comedy was like he
was getting 10 000 episode Carlos and
see it was getting like 7 500 an episode
for Loco slam you know you were hearing
all these little things you know as a
young comic you're like a [__] wash
woman you know anyway what's going on
here what do you think he makes you know
whatever so uh you [__] uh you know
those with those some outrageous [__]
numbers you know
so for me I never thought I would reach
that but I would go to those shows and
just being [__] like it was just
tremendous like everything I didn't care
if my drink was bad I didn't Camp there
was no air conditioning I was just happy
to be there like be a part of something
even as a [__] spectator like I was
like Wow as a comedian someday I'll pay
[__] Caroline's you know
and it's funny because I uh left New
Jersey and I never I never thought I'd
be good enough to play Caroline it's
like never ever ever ever
and then I got a call one night
one day from a friend of mine Roger and
he said listen do you want to do uh he's
a comedy Booker in New York he goes do
you want to do
the Toyota Comedy Festival and I'm like
absofucking lutely you know abso [__]
lutely
Toyota Comedy Festival everybody's going
to Montreal and doing all these
festivals I'm at the [__] lonely New
York City Toyota Comedy Festival
and uh
[__] crazy I went down there
I invited my friends this had to be
maybe 2 000. I got a call from Roger do
you wanna
be on uh the Latino show at Caroline's
for the Toyota Comedy Festival I'm like
[__] yeah in fact God rest his soul the
kid who was putting it together just
died two weeks ago died with a long bout
of cancer Mike Robles got arrested so
but I went down there I'm like guys this
is Caroline's right I'm gonna [__]
get my chance to be on Broadway
the one of these theaters one of these
club Owners is going to see me and run
up to me and give me the deal of a
lifetime and [__] tell me that I'm
great
yeah this is what happens when you do
those things after you know I was at the
comedy store already it's not like I was
walking around with a mind [__] I I was
doing it you know so I get this thing to
go to The Comedy Festival and I get the
Carolines 20 of my friends comes
the show starts at [__] eight guys
you're not gonna believe this this is
just for young Comics to let you know
don't put your all your eggs in a basket
your dream ain't gonna happen it's hard
work that does it day in and day out I
don't give a [__] what anybody tells you
I get there and the [__] uh my
buddies are in the audience I'm excited
I got great material and they come up to
me and they're like we forgot to tell
you we booked the salsa band
so listen man you know like I tell young
comedians don't take it personal this
[__] happens
uh for years I was mad at Mike Robles
over this I mean this happened in 2000 I
didn't start talking to Mike Robles
again till I found out he was sick I
gave him a call I sent some money you
know he did put me on local slam and
that
but I wanted to kill him that night so
my [__] thing was
you know and I tell you guys you know
you guys think that we were [__]
driving around in Mercedes-Benz smoking
big cigars and [__] you died for years
guys you died financially emotionally
every once every four times a year is a
comic you die emotionally you go home
you snort 22 kilos you eat some fat
chicks [__] and you wish for the best
you know what I'm saying I mean that
that's the truth guys because insecurity
is a must because of nights like this so
I get to this [__] Festival the place
is sold out 20 of my high school friends
are there and this [__] tells me
that I'm going up after the salsa band
now I know that's a death sentence right
there right like that's
that's just a [__] recipe for
Destruction you're in no danger of ever
doing anything with your life
every insecurity I felt came back on me
that [__] night quitting High School
getting arrested being a loser
I mean I'm like why the [__] and I
wanted to choke the dude listen I wanted
to choke I kept going up and going dog
why don't we let the band close out the
[__] show it just makes sense
why don't we let the [__] band close
out the show and this mother and this
[__] like
you're strong you and I you know they
would blow smoke up my ass with that
[__] all the time
bro you're a strong actor you know like
all the comics in L.A the Latino Comics
always make me work clean
but when I get to that room it's like
all right you can do what you want but
you got to go on blast [__] while I
gotta go blast for her because you're
dirty they would always blow smoke up my
ass but you're clean you know you're a
killer dog you're I'm not a [__]
killer I'm just dirty knocking the [__]
off these [__]
anyway
[__] 11 30. I'm still not on stage my
friends are getting tired they got to go
to work they'll make the day [__]
they're coming back there knocking on
the door Joey 10 more minutes I know
this [__] the salsa band's up there
you know they're non-union those salsa
bands are non-union they'll go forever
they'll just play those [__] Maracas
forever
I didn't get on stage till like [__]
midnight by the time I got on stage I
was so [__] hot
that I was gonna kill a [__] do
you understand me I just took my [__]
the 50 dollars they gave me I got in the
car with my friends I didn't say a word
they saw me bomb listen
there's a couple things in life I don't
like doing this like going to a game
with a jersey on you ever see these
idiots we're going to the game then the
team loses you got to come home with the
[__] Jersey on all afternoon looking
like an [__] people like ah you went
to the game you [__] idiot and I know
if you're a true fan it don't hurt but
guys like me that [__] bothers me so now
I had to get in the car with the dudes
who just seen me bomb they're like my
best friends but they just saw me
[__] eat a bag of dicks and that
tormenting me in the [__] car and I'm
not talking about you know these nice
guys that goof on each other these are
my friends from North Bergen these guys
are telling me I'm a loser I should get
a day job I'm a [__] bum oh it was
horrible horrible the [__] people
were there from uh
Caroline's I felt like an idiot but
guess what happened
in the middle of all this guys
so you gotta remember no man I don't
care if you get hit by a car
there's always a silver lining okay
maybe you land in a pocket full of money
you know you get hit by a truck you land
over the fence as a [__] 10 naked
women sucking each other off you land
right in the middle of the [__]
Eureka there you are who gives a [__]
that you got 10 broken bones really
seriously here's the silver [__]
lining guys the middle of all my anger
I had all my [__]
just I was just [__] pissed
a girl comes up to me I forget what her
[__] name was I'm still friends with
her you know she calls me in for
different jobs
she goes listen man I just came here to
watch my friend perform
but I saw you and I gotta be honest to
you I I gotta give you like a general
meeting she goes like do you know who
Sheila Jeff is
and I'm like yeah I guess and she's
telling me her and she was like work for
them and I tell you what they're looking
you'd be perfect for The Sopranos
I don't even know what the [__]
Sopranos really were I knew they were a
show they had done the first uh season
and watched like three episodes but I
didn't know it was that [__] big
he came and she told me like listen uh
you know if you could be here tomorrow
at 11 I we'd love that so no matter how
bad the set was and [__] like that was
the only bright spot but come on what
are the chances of me getting the
[__] Sopranos
so that's my [__] Caroline story but
I always felt like [__] I can't go back
in the Carolines now like I bombed so
hard but after that salsa band and you
know guys listen the material was
probably good my timing was good but
sometimes you lose before you even get
to the stage
sometimes something you know and it's
like I tell my wife sometimes listen on
podcast days or comedy days don't bust
my balls I really don't want to hear it
I really don't you know you never know
what happens on the way through if I saw
a comic once that's one of the best
Comics working on the way till we show
you got into a car accident
you know somebody [__] ran a red
light and hit him when this guy got on
the stage and how after the accident he
was [__] you could see he was still
shook after we talked and we smoked some
pot with him and then we gave him a
drink he went up there the second show
and destroyed that [__] room but
sometimes things affect you like things
shake you up you get and for me that
night it was anger after that I checked
I said you know what make sure you don't
get angry I like getting angry before my
shows not too angry there's like a line
there's a fine line like I like getting
a little anger like you know you're
doing something stupid like for me it
was always getting mad at a red band and
for like tape for having matching phones
and [__] what the [__] matching and it
would bother me all day but I wouldn't
say [__] until an hour before the show
because I want to get riled up so if I
have a yell at you before a show just go
he's just [__] getting right after
the show I'll run right through you and
go thank you for getting me riled up I
had a great set because of you
[__] so
so I was just embarrassed to go back to
[__] uh
you know I never I was like [__]
Carowinds I'm never going back in there
in fact I'm never going to 42nd Street
48th Street wherever the [__] it is
and then I was at the store one night it
had to be like 2 000 [__] one
and I gotta I was working and uh so we
were talking and my [__] Idol
my [__] Idol
Paul Mooney tells me hey man what are
you doing this weekend
I go nothing he goes you're from New
York right I go yeah I'm from Jersey
same [__] New York City
he goes you're gonna be there this week
it was like Monday I bumped into him
during the comedy store opened Mike he
goes nah cause if you were there this
weekend I'd have you open for me at
Caroline's I'm like
or what what did you just say
and he goes yeah without me open for me
and Carolyn's I was like
I felt like Tom Mama relationship with
Caroline's but Paul Mooney wasn't from
The Whining comedy school you know if I
told Paul Mooney that story that I went
there and bombed Paul Mooney I don't
even want to tell you what he was saying
to me it wouldn't be [__] nice to say
on this podcast but he wouldn't [__]
go for that [__] that's what made Paul
Mooney Paul Mooney and it built that
[__] spine in us you know what do you
mean you're not gonna go cause you're
bummed that you [__] buddy you
[__] [__] get on the [__] you
know so I didn't say I'll call you
tomorrow and let you know I went home
that night did a couple lines of coke
and I'm like I gotta go back and get
mine you know me dog I'm a revengeful
[__]
the weekend paid 200
it was two shows midnight shows
and they paid me a hundred dollars to
show
two midnight shows my plane ticket was 3
58. I'll never [__] forget this
because I had to borrow that 358 [__]
dollars and pay it back
you know I had to put myself in a hotel
I think thank God Ralphie May was in
town and got me a hotel room or
something like that it was something
crazy they gave him two hotel rooms
and his feature wasn't coming so he just
got a local feature in bananas so I just
had to get myself to New Jersey every
[__] day and that's a piece of cake
so I took the cake even though I was a
loser I was losing [__] 158 dollars
just to prove my [__] point okay I
don't give a [__] what you're doing here
like if you're a plumber and you blow up
some lady's toilet and [__] like that
you're not gonna not go there again
right you're gonna go there and do the
best job you can she's going to remember
you for [__] ever for going back
sometimes man
the respect you know like you apologize
to somebody for something you did 10
years ago and they'll go you know what
man you're respecting my world just went
up 10 for you apologize
sometimes you apologize to yourself
and you get so much more respect out of
yourself that that takes a long
that takes a long sorry this is what
happens after I do a couple [__] bong
hits it shakes up the [__] in my lungs
and I get stuck over here like a little
thickness like somebody came in my
[__] throat I can't imagine having to
suck a dick and somebody comes in your
throat and that thick little [__]
juice just sits there all day and here
you are drinking water and milk and
nothing breaks that [__] it's not
good it's not good so this I'm sorry
about the coffin
but uh yes I'm the type of dude I can't
lose like that and even though I was not
going to make any [__] money
and they were midnight shows which
[__] sucks but not for me because I
picked up spots to warm up for those
midnight shows
I'm gonna forget I got there and Paul
Mooney was like Hey man you're doing a
half hour straight it's a two-man show
I was like [__] again I hate two-man
shows because that means I gotta come
out and walk on them and be a great host
and blah blah blah blah blah
fine I [__] went out there
guys you know I don't blow my own horn
like this I don't know what material I
was saying
but I was not gonna bomb in front of
Paul Mooney do you understand me I was
not gonna bomb all morning either you
were gonna laugh or I was gonna [__]
punch on you until you started [__]
laughing that's the attitude I went out
that night it's fine to bomb you know
Paul seen me bomb at The Comedy Store
and that's fine it's a 15-minute spot
and there's eight people in the audience
you know but I'm not bombing in the full
[__] room sold out to the D
celebrities in the room I'm not bombing
and I went up there guys with the
[__] Fury of I don't know what the
[__] I just went up there with the
weirdest Fury I don't even remember sets
from that time but I made it a point to
[__] destroy that room and I'll never
forget when I walked off to hand the mic
to Paul Mooney he whispered in my head
homie you gotta slow this [__]
down next show and then that and I'll
never forget I was so [__] high on
that Friday night not on drugs not on
coke not on alcohol I was just [__]
high on Comedy and let me tell you
something
I could tell you the FI the five times
in 30 years well I was high off comedy
and that is a great feeling and for
years people always talk about wow when
a comic gets off stage
this is why they get you know they get
to do drugs to continue that when you're
doing little spots you don't really feel
that it's when you do an hour and you're
there
like after like like I was never excited
after my special tapings
but like uh
what did I do a couple years ago that
was just it was like my first theater or
something and I thought my timing would
be off and my timing was better than
expected when I got off that stage I was
[__] uh what do you call that [__]
when you float like I was I was just
walking on air
but that Caroline set was so [__]
powerful
I had a couple tears in my eyes after
Moon he went on stage and I went to The
Green Room I don't know I forget
somebody who worked there came up to me
and they were like dog that's the best
set we've seen from a feature Act
a long [__] time I'm like thank you
and they left and they didn't understand
where I was [__] coming from
I'll never forget that I went
to the back of the room to watch Paul
Mooney even though I had seen him a
hundred thousand times
I couldn't go anywhere like I couldn't
talk to anybody like I was that it was
like
Revenge it was [__] Revenge it was
like somebody it was death wish somebody
rapes your mother and then you put 10
bullets in his dick you know it's
[__] Revenge as his best but in a
comedic sort of way like a personal type
of Vendetta I'm never forget I'm sitting
back there
minding my own [__] business just
watching Paul Mooney going
I'm gonna do this for the next 10
[__] years I barely made it to this
I'm a Caroline's after 10 years I
finally killed the Carolines I got one
more show left but the way I'm [__]
feeling right now I'm gonna kill in the
middle of all this just it was like Paul
Mooney was talking on stage but I could
not understand the word he was saying
like I was just watching that's that's
how much my body was just [__] like
percolating I wasn't thinking of cocaine
I wasn't thinking of getting cocaine I
wasn't thinking of getting anybody
[__] look up and I see
the girl that plays
like there was a bunch of people that I
I saw on television there a lot of soap
opera people
that I had just seen over the years I
don't even know what their [__] their
names are
but I saw a lot of people that were like
a couple basketball players were there
from the Knicks that night people were
saying they had security with them
but when I [__] out of all the and
they were all African-American and I
understand that they were at a
three-point morning
but the the whole night was made for me
when I popped my head up at one time and
I looked over and the girl from
League of Their Own
you ever see the league the other one
the girl that [__] is her sister Gina
Davis is a sister Laurie I like to say
Laurie Metcalf or something like that I
don't know what her name yes Tank Girl
[__] I'm sitting there like this
watching Paul Mooney in awe and just
letting myself come down from whatever
the [__] just happened in my world
and I [__] look over and see Tank
Girl
and she's watching Paul Mooney like all
in right like all in right this is a
white girl that's watching a black dude
destroy white people on stage at this
point at night he's destroying black
people I'm gonna forget that night guys
I'm gonna forget the jokes he was saying
that night some Africans were there and
they heckled them and he threw him the
[__] out he goes get the [__] out of
here you [__] Africans where
the [__] were you when I needed you
showing up now 20 years later with a
[__] watch to sell me he was just
throwing people out of that room oh my
God he was on a rope all morning
but poor Laurie Metcalf that's her name
Tank Girl
was saying his [__] jokes guys so
let's say
Paul Mooney was saying a joke
she was [__] talking it over like she
knew his material and I'm like what the
[__]
and out of nowhere she caught me and she
walked over like after like 20 minutes
Laurie Petty she came over she goes bro
you had a good [__] set and I go
thank you I go how do you know Paul
Mooney and she's like blah blah went to
parties I used to go to The Comedy Store
10 years ago I went to Richard's house
for parties
well Paulie yeah so she knew comedy you
know so
she was like you did great but you know
you're gonna hang out she was doing a
play in New York City at the time
so she goes are you hanging out and I go
yeah [__] yeah I'm hanging out there was
food and drinks and a bunch of [__] but
after the show it's just
I'm the type of guy I know where I don't
belong you know what I'm saying like I
just didn't belong there I went back
there I talked to Laurie Paul Mooney
gave me a hug he was like great set
homie you know blah blah blah and then I
was like you know what I'm gonna take a
[__] walk because at that time it was
like one in the morning it's like 2 30
in the morning here we are I'm 48 in
[__] Broadway I gotta get back to
[__] Jersey
I met some kid Jimmy
I saw him years later in L.A I don't
know what he's doing now I met a kid
Jimmy that night
and I'll never forget Jimmy was like
like [__]
he was maybe an open Miker at the time
he when I when I went outside he's like
man I've been waiting for you
that was tremendous I've been doing
comedy for four years that's what I want
to be can I buy you a slice of pizza and
you could talk to me about the recipe
about what you did I'll never forget
this [__] and I was like let's go and we
walked around we got a slice of pizza
and then uh
I went to Port Authority I don't even
think [__] buses were running
I don't even think buses are running I
remember that I was [__] wired
I don't know how I got home but I went
to my buddy's house
and I stood outside this house I hadn't
seen him in like 10 years and I hadn't
seen him in like six years seven years
and I heard he was living there and I
went and I stood outside his house he's
my friend Darren Rago he died like uh
maybe a year after I didn't see him
because I remember when they called me
and told me he died I go I just [__]
saw him but I'll never forget I stayed
out there all night
by myself on this [__] Pub porch and
about eight o'clock I rang his doorbell
and he answered he lived on like a
building not a house
and we went to get [__] breakfast and
the next that Saturday night I went to
[__] Caroline's
and leveled them
even worse than I did the night before
it was [__] tremendous I gave Paul a
hug to give him my check for 200 and I
went home and I got in the plane but
guess what it wasn't about the 200 it
wasn't about losing
the 156 on the plane ticket and meals
and expenses it was but I had to know
you ever see [__] uh
Dirty Harry the scene in Dirty Harry one
of the first shootouts where he's having
coffee and these guys are trying to rob
a bank and he's like what the [__] I'm
trying to have [__] coffee here you
could see it as he's walking out with
his gun he's wiping his [__] face he
had like jelly roll juice on his face
and he's walking down and he starts
shooting people and listen this is one
dude on the floor a [__] guy
African-American dude he did a thousand
movies great actor he's on the floor and
Clint Eastwood takes the [__] gun
from like kicks it away and he goes you
know this is the most powerful gun in
the world or clean your [__] whatever
and Austin Clint Eastwood seize his hand
moving to get the gun you know what
scene I'm talking about and he go clean
so looks at him and shoot him and he
goes I got to know
gots to know like because Clint's told
him you got
six in the chamber and you already shot
five or maybe six if you feel lucky go
for the [__] gun
and Clint just did say they were looking
at him also the guy goes I gotta know if
there's six or seven in that
[__] and then when Lisa picks up
the gun points it at him and goes let's
find out and he just goes and the guy is
like [__] he opens he goes now you
know all right it's the same thing I had
to know
I don't know if I really had it I had to
know that
I can [__] do it man so that's why
there's nothing wrong with that
you got to prove your point sometimes if
you know you could back it up you gotta
back it up and guess what
I never went back to Capital things
again
never never when I was trying to get
into New York
they wouldn't [__] uh take me
that's the truth and it was because of
that [__] bombing 10 years earlier I
mean what uh this is why I tell comics
don't go anyplace you don't belong until
you're ready because if they see you and
you bomb it's going to take years to
take away that embalming and that's a
problem with a lot of club Owners they
see you when you're starting off you go
in there you know you you just did great
you just did great at Vinnie's House of
Pizza pies you know you did seven
minutes and some [__] guy that told
you you're the next Andrew Dice Clay so
you put yourself in a bad position and
you go to an open mic on one of those
punch lines on one of those improvs and
[__] like that let me tell you something
you eat a bag of dicks how many improvs
are there 40 28 of them are gonna find
that if you eat a bag of dicks at a
punch line that's like six clubs I think
they got Sacramento San Francisco
Atlanta Philadelphia do you follow how
this goes so when you go into these like
I was ready for Karen lines the first
time I wanted that I was already not
established but I was already a regular
at some stores and I was working as a
[__] feature act if you're not
[__] established and you walk into
these clubs and you eat a bag of dicks
10 years later they're going to call
that club and if that lady or that that
man or who or whatever the [__] they
call themselves now if that's still
there they're gonna go Mike Klein Mike
Klein
yeah I remember Mike he didn't [__]
he started here in Denver and Boulder
and you're like yeah that's him so can
we have a week and they're like nah he
didn't do too good last time he was here
and the agent's like when was he there
like 10 years ago he ate a bag of dicks
here and the agent's like well can't we
get him back and give him another chance
well if he wants to come through and do
a showcase that'd be great but we can't
make an offer and you're like what like
when I got into comedy I never worked
Denver
[Music]
Denver clubs would not hire me and then
they kept getting out of business The
Comedy Club went out of business
mcelvey's went out of business
and I'd been thrown out of the Comedy
Works
this is why you don't that's why people
always go nobody hires me at home
fairy seldom that's a comic who came up
in Philly come home to Philly and
[__] work a club because they
remember them from [__] 10 years ago
they're like ah we don't want you around
here
very seldom do you get the war like New
Jersey
how many clubs that I work in Jersey all
those years
not too [__] many I would come to
Jersey do the stretch and I'm talking
about two thousand I'm talking about 20
[__] years ago did you see what
happened yesterday I'll bring it up in a
second I'm talking 20 [__] years ago
20 years ago I would come to Jersey and
I had to beg these guys
that I would tell them I'm from Jersey
I'm at the store I worked The Improv I
do this I just shot an episode of this I
did a movie
I still remember calling Uncle Uncle
Vinnies
10 years ago when the podcasts and stuff
and he's like I don't know you don't
call here again you know that that's
just the way it is guys that's the way
it is
nobody wanted to hire me in Jersey when
I [__] nobody wanted to hire me in
Jersey and nobody wanted to hire me in
New York
and Gotham stepped up
then all the clubs found out the damage
that they got them and they're like ah
we'll take Joey now it's too [__]
late
got them already [__] took great care
of me why the [__] would I uh you know
want to go to that thing anyway that's
my Caroline story on a Wednesday
afternoon I just wanna
Thursday
oh no that's it I don't even know when
it's going to close
there's a girl that reaches out to me
from time to time I did a podcast about
a year ago after the many Saints came
out
and she [__] uh
she does the individual shows there she
did the show November 30th but I wasn't
available if she contacts me again I'll
go over there I know that uh
my boy uh
papa is doing a show in the village next
week
and I'm thinking of going in one night
10 minutes 12 minute spot go over there
they're all woke so it's all NYU
students so they're just gonna stare at
me but I just like to go to I can't love
to just go down there to go off on them
and watch them because if you're not
gonna laugh at me and go off on me for
being the man that I am I'm gonna go off
at you for being the worm that you are
almost we'll walk now go [__] yourself
yesterday I woke up to a bunch of
[__] messages from people it was the
weirdest thing Tuesday morning
like why the [__] are people hitting me
December 6th like congratulations 20
years from Analyze That I'm like
wow
wow I actually had to sit there for a
second
and go what the [__] again Analyze That
which one did I do analyze this is the
second one to analyze that is the second
one
Analyze That was the first one
I was already in L.A
and I'll never forget I went down to the
Sunset Boulevard the big Plex the Dome
the [__] great theater they have
chicken sausages with [__] oh my God
chicken and apple sausage with something
else it's [__] delicious
and uh I really enjoyed
analyze this the first one I thought it
was [__] great and I can't lie to you
those are the days whenever I go see a
movie and I thought I could be in that
movie I'd get [__] pissed off I sit
there and go [__] I could have been in
this movie but I'm a stand-up nobody's
gonna [__] talk to me about goddamn
acting and [__]
and I thought it was a great movie I saw
Harold Ramis directed it and he was one
of my favorite directors of all [__]
time
and uh I don't know that was another
thing I just wanted to get a piece of
like I was like I gotta get in that
[__] if they ever do one of these
again and I'll never forget that I went
in
for an audition of a mind of a dangerous
man or something like that
it was the story of Chuck Barris
I think that's his name the guy that
used to host the gun show
so
I wasn't thinking anything I did my
lines I read I was prepared I went to
see a coach but I knew I wouldn't get
the role because it was a roll for some
Spanish dude as a matter of fact
I knew it was it belonged to
Louis Guzman I go as I was reading it
I'm like this is Louis Guzman's and he
needed another Mexican dude in there I
know this is Louis Guzman's it Lewis is
Puerto Rican but they were looking for
like Puerto Rican guys
and I read for her I I forgot what her
name was
I read for her I read for her
Sheila Jaffrey and walking so I had met
Georgian walking
when I read for The Sopranos the first
time and Georgian on the way out
told me to keep in touch with her
she goes keep in touch with me and send
me reels to anything that you do
which is always a great sign when
somebody leaves the door open like that
so I never really thought about it
I went
it was December
and I went in to see
Sheila Jaffe in L.A for that Mind of a
dangerous man I think that's the name of
the movie I don't know it's a Chuck
Barris autobiography
I get a man I read but Mama it's not
going my way I mean I did a good read
but I knew it wasn't for me
she she looked at me she goes you did a
great job but
this this
is Louis Guzman throw she goes I know we
started talking and she goes but
the next movie I'm working on I'm lying
it wasn't Sheila Jaffe it was the same
lady I read for De Niro a couple weeks
ago
she goes the movie
I'm happy you came in it's not going to
work for you the next movie I'm doing
it's your movie and I go what are you
doing and she goes Analyze That
I didn't care if it sucked I didn't know
what the script was didn't matter to me
I just knew I wanted in on this [__]
movie
so she goes she told me the same thing
Joe Jan Walken said to me she goes
whatever the [__] you need whatever you
shoot or whatever mail me a [__] a
real I go fine and I wasn't out that
[__] office 10 minutes I got a
call from my agent to go read for Fox
uh
a [__] show about two gay gangsters
the mesos
and I'm like why and he goes yeah this
was the deal that big [__] left The
Sopranos for but then ABC didn't want to
do it and it reverted back to Fox so now
fox wants to do a short film to see if
they can explore this and you know see
what kind of characters they get go read
for it so I went I read for it I ended
up booking and we shot the first week of
January no big deal but I kept telling
those guys listen they're shooting
analyze that and I want to get in on
that so do me a favor just give me two
scenes from this movie two [__]
scenes is all I need two clips two
minute scenes the guys are so cool I'll
never forget their name Joe or Pino or
something like that little gay dude he's
got the best job in America now he's a
director he makes six figures he works
nine to five and no weekends he's a
director
for videos that build stuff at Costco no
Ikea Ikea so when you see it when you
buy a [__] futon at Ikea and you
wanted directions to build it you put
that video in he directs those videos
[__] best job in California he sent
me two clips I got him to that lady
and then she called me and she goes Hey
Joe would you like to audition if I
analyze that I'm like [__] yeah
and she goes okay you gotta read in New
York
and I was like no problem
I'll go to [__] New York because
there was no auditions on tape back then
at least not for me on that project
so I'll never [__] forget I come back
from New York the auditions on my
birthday
I'm like my
I don't know 40 something birthday 42nd
41st
I [__] I don't have the money for the
plane ticket I'm staying on my buddy
George's couch
and uh I probably got 25 bucks in my
pocket I'm flat [__] broke
I didn't know I was gonna get a plane
ticket so I called my buddy in Denver he
worked for Frontier
he got me a buddy pass on Frontier which
means you're lucky if you even get there
with this [__] buddy pass I know
Frontier is doing that New Deal 100 600
and you fly the rest of the year for
free good luck with that you don't know
about that starts in may not a bad
program look into it
so I take the Frontier Airline and it's
a connecting flight you got to go
through Denver and they lose my luggage
I mean I got in at 11 in the morning and
my audition was a [__] two
they lost my [__] luggage on my
[__] birthday
so I had to borrow 50 bucks from my
brother shoot down to some [__]
Marshalls buy a warm-up suit sneakers
underwear head gel yeah the whole thing
and even though I was ruffled this time
I didn't bomb I [__] went down to the
Village read for her and how ramus and
knocked it out of the [__] Park and
as a matter of fact before I went down
there I went to see my stepfather and
they gave me the Indian ring the ring
that I have for everything tell you I
worn that on every movie role I've had
any Italian roles anything like that I
don't know if it get putting the ring on
for the audition
getting the audition booking the role
and then it became my [__] lucky ring
for you people to know I got the lucky
ring
and I'll never forget shooting that
[__] like we shot it maybe 20
minutes from where I'm living right now
I drive by there every once in a while
and go oh my God this is just changed so
much they wanted me to go into the City
and meet them over here at like eight in
the morning I'm like whoa so I'm in
Jersey already I'm down here I was
staying in Morganville which is 10
minutes from here I go you want me to go
all the way into the city until I get in
a van with you [__] and come
all the way back here to Kearney New
Jersey and they're like yeah I go all
right I said that's not gonna work I
just meet you at Carney and I went
[__] great day of shooting 12-hour
day talked to Harold Ramis for maybe
nine of those hours had no contact with
DeNiro just saw him socially [__] fan
out
um it was just a [__] great day man I
couldn't wait for that I'm like that's
it I made it like I worked so hard to
get that [__] movie besides acting
coach you know I just went and I got
shot I got shot in the first [__]
middle of the movie that's when I had
the beginning of the movie every movie I
did was in the beginning that Taxi
but uh
it was just I don't know I think it was
the Harold Ramis thing
I think it was Anthony Lombard there
just I I
that movie was the first time I could
look at people that said that you ain't
gonna do nothing like Mad TV was one
thing and basketball is the other but a
dinero movie with my scenes being with
Anthony lombaglia who at that time was
the star of his own [__] meant the
world to me guys that that that right
there I could tell a lot of people to
suck my dick after that all those people
had said well you're not castable well
it's a [__] dinero movie with Harold
Ramis go [__] yourself so I was very
proud of that movie and I remember Doug
I can tell you things
I was dying to get my hand on that reel
from that movie so we were doing
everything we could and I'm gonna tell
you a funny story a guy from the Army I
was he used to promote shows that I
would do for a certain promoter or
something like that he would help him
out and he's like man I gave you that
tape and I go out and he goes you tap
into Warner Brothers film base because
they move everything on some I mean this
guy told me should I never even knew in
fact I can't even repeat I don't
remember how they did it everything they
do all the movies and editing is through
online he goes if you tap into it you
can hack their thing and get it he calls
me two weeks later I got it for you
it's hacked done I got it it's like the
movie comes out December 6th and um
people like send me that tape so we can
see if we can put you in this movie I'm
[__]
first off the movie's gonna come out I
can't tape in the movie theater so I
gotta wait for the movie to come on DVD
for me off VHS whatever the [__] it was
the format was and then I could take a
snippet of that the studios are not
going to send me a snippet for me to
[__] so we get the snippet my friend
steals the Snipping off the studio so
we're gonna have it ready for this thing
as soon as the movie comes out we're
gonna have our real
when you steal it from the movie it
comes out backwards
so instead of me being on like this side
I was really on this side now we had to
get somebody to flip it around I had to
call 80 [__] Studios to flip it
around nobody could do it this one dude
with a missing eye said he'd do it for
me I got down that guy's got one missing
eye he's smoking cigarettes it's dark in
there he looks at he goes I could do it
but I won't
and I go why not he goes because I go to
jail for 10 years that's probably a
Warner Brothers I'm not doing that and
that was the end of my
the movie came out I'll never forget I
went with like 20 of my friends Josh
Wolf we all went we all chipped and
we're all broke we had like peanuts and
[__]
Doug the movie started there I am and
then I got shot and then we had to sit
there for two hours and watch this
god-awful [__] movie I was never so
embarrassed in my life but hey I got the
[__] movie I didn't know it was gonna
suck that's my [__] that's my analyze
that story and that's it [__]
it's Wednesday the 8th Thursday
the [__] eight we've done it again
another week down we got [__]
basically three weeks
till uh
my show in uh Sony theater and we
basically got
two and a half weeks for [__]
Christmas we're sticking around
listen leave a great Christmas idea
because people keep asking me people
really liked these laughing gas things
as a matter of fact the male girl asked
me the other day if she could have a
sticker okay how the [__] does she even
know I had stickers people like the
Laughing Gas what I'm doing for you guys
this holiday is 20 off any of the gear
just you code Coco Coco laughing gas.com
get whatever the [__] you want 20 off
for the holidays use code Coco and don't
forget oh my God [__] New York
Stoner Club has some [__] weed some
Indica in New York
he gave me some a couple days ago I took
three hits off a joint that he gave like
a pre-roll
they're not [__] around over that if
you live in New York City right now
order
I'm gonna hook you up 10 off lifetime
Uncle Joey at Stoners Club
.com it's that [__] easy guys I gave
you 20 off on the [__] uh
memorabilia whatever the [__] you call
it uh schmerch and 10 off on weed for
Life who's better than your Uncle Joey
nobody you bad [__] was still
set for the [__] uh
28th of December it's my wife's birthday
I'm writing some material I'm excited
and uh that's it and that's that guys we
[__] killed this [__] another
week in a row stay black I love you and
don't forget about me
I'll see you next Monday and now for a
word my [__] sponsors Jackie
all right I want to thank you guys for
taking a tremendous year beat until I
had some fun so who gives a [__] listen
I want to welcome
rocketmoney.com most Americans think
they spend around 80 a month on
subscriptions but you're wrong it's
close to like 200. those numbers add up
you could be wasting hundreds of dollars
each month on subscriptions you didn't
even know you had that's why I love
rocket money formerly known as true bill
the app shows all your subscriptions in
one place and cancel whatever ones you
don't want rocket money can even find
subscriptions you didn't even know you
were paying for you may even find out
you've been double charged for a
subscription to take the subscription
just press cancel and Rocket money takes
care of the rest it's that easy get rid
of useless subscriptions right now with
rocketmoney.com showy again that's
rocketmoney.com Joey you're gonna save
hundreds of dollars per year cancel your
unnecessary subscriptions right now at
rocketmoney.com
Joey the joint is also brought to you by
my [__] favorite DraftKings why it's
fun and they're the official sports
betting partner of the UFC this Saturday
at UFC 282 and that's great you got five
dollar pre-fight money line on any
fighter to win and you get a hundred and
fifty dollars in free bets when they do
but we also got college football we got
college basketball we got pro football
pro basketball and you're sitting there
[__] boy to Pieces 20 days before the
holidays I'm gonna put an extra deuce in
your pocket before Christmas right now
everyone can earn up to a few 50 boost
when you place the same game probably on
UFC 282 so do me a favor download the
app today use promo code Joey j-o-e-y
and bet five dollars on pre five money
line on any fight in the win and you'll
get a buck 50 when they do that's called
Joey this Saturday at DraftKings
Sportsbook D official sports betting
partner UFC minimum age and eligibility
restrictions apply she show notes for
details it's that easy to play to win
Jack and liquid IV come on they're the
best time hydration has to be on the top
of your daily list it's like eating
chicken cutlets liquid IV is the same
way to stay hydrated you get five
essential vitamins and you hydrate two
times faster than with water alone just
with one stick of liquid IV cooler
weather makes it even easier to miss
scientists dehydration like overeating
so it's important to stay hydrated
listen I use it when I'm in Jiu Jitsu
I'll put in my little drink there and
I'll drink from it and I feel tremendous
afterward why because they contain five
essential vitamins B3 B5 B6 B12 and
vitamin C they got all the beasts made
with premium ingredients liquid IV is
free from gluten dairy and soy so grab
your liquid IV and bump nationwide at
Costco or at liquid iv.com use promo
code Joey at checkout that's 20 off
anything with code Joey at liquid iv.com
I want to thank liquid IV I want to
thank better help I want to thank
rocketmoney.com I want to thank
DraftKings I want to thank all you
[__] savages for listening and for
having my back we'll be back Monday
morning Tip Top Maguey Louie stay black
I love you Scott suckers
foreign
[Music]